after you decide which model you wish to
implement it's time to ship it and learn
from it what is working and what's not
well go into the details of how to track
success in the next lesson but it's
important to get the hooks in place
early so that you can monitor
performance later at this point you also
probably want to track as much as
possible think about any actions and
events that you can learn from and add
them to the tracking so that it's set by
default if you have a decent audience it
might be a good idea to test your model
on X percentages of the users and learn
from it if you want to learn more about
a/b testing we've linked to another a be
testing course on Udacity in the
instructor notes in the next node will
provide resources telling you exactly
how to set up tracking in your product
we recommend that you follow the steps
now to get things set up early if you
currently don't have a product that you
can track then we recommend reading
through the resources to familiarize
yourself with the process and then
bookmark relevant resources to return to
later